you
so what's next on the on the journey of
Jake's journey well what what so what so
what's what are you looking forward to
like what's right now me and my wife
Ryan Ryan James shut up about wow wow
wow we're about to move into Philly on
the 11th moving up to Philly she's from
there and just more work opportunity for
a piece of [ __ ] like me yeah she got a
badass job up there so like any city we
go to we know somebody we can stay with
and ride the couch yeah [ __ ] like that
and it's it's it's been awesome I meant
like I've met a lot of [ __ ] cool
people just all over and it just makes
you want to be like there's there's more
to life than just right here yeah right
now where I'm living at yeah I've lived
that my whole life because I mean the
house I'm living in right now is across
the street from the house being Luke
grew up in what would you say that what
would you say to the 2007 Jake James
who's sitting right here oh [ __ ] thank
you it's been a wild ride
oh yeah no it's been nuts man but I mean
it's just who knows I kind of believe in
all that like don't change like I
wouldn't change nothing just like if
that's how it worked out you know what I
mean
yeah so everything's been forged in
steel and so good yeah I would go
through all that again to be where I'm
at right now basically in an epic
journey yeah I mean the whole thing it's
like maybe someday I will do something
with myself ha ha ha I mean but I mean
I'm doing I'm doing the best I can for
what it is and I love it I love I love
my life right now more than anything
that's always change anything hell yeah
dude that was [ __ ] legendary dude
yeah yeah thanks for coming out man dude
I know a lot of you want to be able to
take this and learn from it and there's
a lot of people who relate to stories
well I know you know he's leaving and
he's moving on the next chapter of his
life yep so I hope whether you think you
can or you
you're right never forget that goddamn
right
[Laughter]